back to our special one-hour visit to
Finland now up until now I've been
haunting the great city of Helsinki but
much of Finland's 130,000 square miles
is pristine untamed wilderness and I
wanted to take a look so I flew north to
Lapland above the Arctic Circle
home to reindeer herds the ancient Sami
people the Northern Lights and of course
Santa Claus okay we made it here we are
this sign means we were at the actual
Arctic Circle we came here because house
inky just wasn't cold enough
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm headed to a reindeer farm it's an
amazing region of natural beauty
untouched by human hands of course the
only way to get there he's on a
diesel-powered fuel belching incredibly
loud snowmobile right here but trust me
this place could use a little global
warming
[Music]
name is nila Yahweh nila smells
delicious
Neela's yoni I am kkona kkona real Sami
man
native lapis people are Sami people you
can tell the future by drumming on this
dress Oksana to live I wouldn't kappa
liam the command ayyy LMAO kappa ah he
can tell the forecast the weather with
this let me guess
cold and snowy we also teach you how the
reindeer speak is own language this is
that's how the Rangers speak yes they're
kind of moving away I've noticed what
are you telling them excited ed ed
what's that head off right here that's
it huh yeah there's a reindeer that
could just about the coffee reindeer let
us now hear the yolk song of the
reindeer
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty good you know I just realize you
know who he looks like he looks a lot
like tough-guy American actor Charles
Bronson I kill you punk
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Annina
yes and you're going to teach me how to
ride the dogsled exactly is it difficult
no if you follow my instructions mm-hmm
very controlling I like that in a woman
no usually six but then if you want to
race them 12 what's the most anyone's
ever uses ooh never use like six hundred
dogs and tried to break this wave sound
you go ski what is it what is it what
you're trying to tell me something I am
bored get stuck in a sound huh yeah
torkoal can tell this guy's mad about
something cuz he's been peeing on the
roof of his own house
are there verbal commands or signals
that you give to the dogs yes we what
are they I should learn those now what
are they know oh right
oh yeah Boyka yes left is a button left
is button yes
do you mind if I have a few of my own
yeah okay hurry quickly we must go
quickly I want that to be I had been
told all right
come come my fellow dogs lead me to
victory that would be over the hill and
see the dogs
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]